this is not a kids movie in any way
shape or form this is an adult batman
movie at any point was warner brothers
like
you know nervous about the subject
matter and you know what i mean
you know what's so interesting is that
they
and it's to me that's like the
experience on the film they have been so
incredibly supportive and they loved
from the inception you know the pitch
once i wanted to put it into this world
and that i wanted to do a kind of sort
of detective story noir and that whole
thing they were very responsive they
were very excited about that i think
they knew that you know i said from the
beginning
to do a standalone batman film you
really have to there's a there's a long
line of great movies and so the idea
that you can come and just do another
batman film it has to be a great batman
film you have to set out to do something
that feels distinctive and different and
definitive and so they embraced it the
whole time there was never a moment
where they said to me are you sure let's
not they they really leaned into
everything and i've had the support to
do exactly i mean i have to say this
movie
is exactly the movie i wanted it to be
and they have supported me all the way
through it so no there was never
really that moment they one thing they
they did knew which was my intention
from the beginning was they said look
it's important to us that the movie be
pg-13 we want to make sure that we can
get this it's a batman movie and we're
investing so much in it and i was like
well you know
in the apes movies i tried to sort of
find that balance as well they were
meant to be sort of you know they were
obviously spectacle and grand
entertainment but there was a level of
intensity and i felt like in that same
way i knew that we could push the
boundaries of what you could do in a
pg-13 movie and still deliver everything
i wanted to do
um you i know you test screened the
movie you know every movie gets test
screened what did you learn from those
exactly so what did you learn from those
early screenings and did you actually
make changes to the movie as a result of
those well you always make subtle
changes to make sure that things that
are not clear are are clear or if
they're sections that don't feel like
they're moving in the right way
to me honestly the first version of this
movie that i screened the movie is a
very ambitious
complex narrative and so by the time we
got to a place where we had to start
testing i was not all the way through
the cut of the movie i had you know
there was so much of the movie yet to be
touched and it was really long i mean
not to say that the movie doesn't have
length now but it was longer than what i
intended and so i was terrified because
i thought oh my gosh we're showing this
before i'm ready to an audience and in
terms of a batman movie it's a very
complex detective story narrative are
they going to be able to follow anything
and what i found actually which was
amazing was how much they loved that
aspect that was the biggest relief i was
thinking okay why did i do this why did
i decide to make this kind of story and
what the first test screening told me
was the audience wanted this that you
know we had the batmobile chases we had
all the things you can't make a batman
movie without giving the baseline things
that people want from a batman movie but
i knew we were challenging the audience
in this kind of world's greatest
detective side because it was going to
be a very complex narrative and it
turned out they loved that part of it it
was one of the things that tested best
so that part was a great thing to learn
which was that actually the audience
would be excited about this version of
the movie and that only continued to get
better as we continue to test and then i
i finally just made my way bit by bit
through the cut and you make tiny
adjustments to make sure that little
things that maybe are not clear enough
are clearer but it uh the testing
process kind of validated that this was
a direction that an audience would be
excited about for me what was thrilling
was they didn't know what they were
seeing so they would come to a screening
and then suddenly they realized they
were seeing a batman movie and there was
it showed how much love there is for
batman which was so exciting for me
because of course i've loved this since
i was a kid and to be in an audience and
have that big screen experience after
we're all been away from it for so long
and to see people cheer and to see
people get excited and then to see them
get wrapped up i mean there'd be moments
where there was just utter silence and
you're like okay people are people love
batman and they're into this and that
was exciting that to me was the best
part of the testing uh i know you had a
longer cut um is there a chance even
though this is a long movie is there a
chance that fans will ever see like an
extended version or a lot of deleted
scenes you know this is the cut that the
amazing thing about this process and i
have to say like when you asked me at
the beginning about warner brothers and
was their pushback
this is the version of the film that i
wanted to make and the amazing thing is
i got to make it which is a great i mean
look i always enter everything by saying
like look you might not want my version
of this and that's it's yours right this
is your franchise so i'm a custodian for
a period of time if you choose me but if
you choose me then choose me because you
want to do what i want to do and if you
don't like what i want to do that's
totally fine just don't hire me and you
know i've been really lucky that with
the apes films those are the movies i
wanted to make it's not like there's
some other cut somewhere this particular
experience at warner brothers was just
the same this is the version and you
know what it's look it's a big expansive
crazy detective movie it is all these
other things that a batman movie should
be and they let me make it and there is
not another cut
you